these children are those kite strings
that lift our national ambitions aloft
and how we treat them is the measure of
what kind of decency and honor we have
as a society we also want that future to
be better for our children so this is
all about the children
for decades Democrats have tried to
convince women that they care more about
them and the children than Republicans
care well it's always been a lame
campaign tactic and it's always pegged
to these tedious cliches and to their
support for things like abortion and
food stamps meanwhile Republicans think
women value things like I don't know
prosperity a good job and safe streets
but that's not all mothers and fathers
of course also greatly value education
and anyone who has or has had children
knows there's no substitute for
in-person learning from teachers in an
actual school with peers and
extracurricular activities I love make
kids and my customer all laughing and
there's talking and there's movement and
busyness and I've gotten from that to a
totally different thing where I'm an IT
person looking at a screen all day we're
certainly concerned about everyone's
safety that's that's paramount
there's a there's essential businesses
that have to get work done and we think
educating our kids is essential thus
after three and a half months of
distance learning don't you hate that
phrase for millions of American students
exhausted parents coast-to-coast and
especially mothers are really anxious
about what the fall will bring for their
children and themselves as moms who work
outside the home are beginning to head
back into the office they need to know
that their sons and daughters will be
heading back to school Monday through
Friday you know like they did in the PC
era pre kovat yet just yesterday in
Fairfax County Virginia one of the most
affluent and populous suburbs of
Washington DC the democrat-controlled
School District made the shocking
announcement that it's not going to be
fully reopening in the fall instead
families are given two options enrolling
their kids in 100% online classes for
days per week or in-person classes for
just two days a week now with the latter
option kids will have to remain six feet
apart at all times daily health
screenings and regular hand washing and
sanitizing now it's similar to a plan
being put forward by the neighboring
Loudoun County Virginia another wealthy
county controlled by Democrats we have a
lot of those in the DC area
I wonder why now that was just a few
days ago now parents in both counties
are rightfully outraged one parent
telling a local ABC station I also have
seen the repercussions at home where
they were distancing I saw depression I
saw them lose interest in life and I
can't sit by and watch that happen again
well she's right we can't let this
happen again
we know the heavy toll this is taking on
children's mental health the vast
majority of children are very very low
risk of any serious consequences of this
disease keeping kids out of school is
causing enormous harm to them we know
from studies now out of China the
depression rates in kids who have been
locked down are up 20 to 30 percent
we know that children from low-income
families in particular who are being
homeschooled if we're waiting for
children to be immunized before they go
back to school we could be looking at
two three four years that's an eternity
for now of course living in this area
we're used to mistakes by left-wing
out-of-touch elites who don't fully
appreciate the real-world consequences
of their actions but it would be
terrible a terrible shame if these two
counties set an example for the rest of
America now I'm sure the folks in
Fairfax County will claim they're only
doing these extreme measures because of
the virus for Public Health but that's
just absurd there is no science that
supports keeping kids especially those
in the younger grades away from the
classroom NPR reported yesterday that
throughout the pandemic both the YMCA
and the New York City Education
Department kept childcare centers open
for the children of frontline workers
they collectively took care of tens of
thousands of kids for months so guess
how many kovat outbreaks were linked to
they're staying open zero furthermore a
survey by Brown University economist
Emily Auster found that just point one
six percent of the 20,000 children at
916 care centers across the country work
ovid positive 0.16 the evidence for
reopening our schools is overwhelming
elliott Haspel an education policy
expert with the Robbins Foundation
saying there are almost no recorded
cases of child to adult transmission of
koban 19 it's not a zero risk but we're
acting with a march 2020 understanding
of kovat 19 and kids with not with a
June 2020 understanding of Kovan 19 and
kids Democrats usually love citing
Europe's approach to things right so
let's see how the Europeans are handling
this decision
well European countries that have
for hire Cova death rates than we did
such as French and Belgian Belgium have
already sent students back to school
Italy in Spain are reopening schools in
September and of course Sweden never
closed its lower schools at all no
significant outbreaks in these countries
have been reported due to school
attendance
now unfortunately Fairfax County isn't
listening the student body and Fairfax
happens to be one of the most diverse in
America nearly twenty-six percent
Hispanic eight percent African American
twenty-three percent Asian and
thirty-eight percent white thousands of
these parents are essential workers
others live paycheck to paycheck there
are others who are really wealthy of
course but what are the people who are
less advantaged supposed to do here how
is that going to work our women the
people that Democrats care so much about
are they can have to quit their jobs to
homeschool their kids
how can Governor Ralph Northam
countenance this and how much of the
teachers unions driving this decision
are these decisions at all influenced by
politics the answer to the last two
questions is likely a lot keep the chaos
going through the fall in the streets
and in the homes it'll be terrible for
the larger economy terrible for the
unemployment numbers and god-awful for
students not a good situation for any
incumbent president now politics is
already poised in the school curricula
across America
propaganda from the radical and reckless
16:19 project already seeping into
history classes we talked about that
last week a sensible school choice
initiatives they're blocked by Democrats
they trap poor minority kids and
underperforming schools but politics
should never affect whether schools open
for regular classes in the coming days
and weeks school districts across
America will be announcing their
decisions on schedules and classroom
learning mothers and fathers should make
their voices heard on this loud and
clear our kids need to be back in school
period widespread closure
we'll have terrible long-term
consequences for our children and will
do little if anything to stop Koba 19
things like hand sanitizing stations
even temperature checks at the door they
could easily be implemented without
throwing millions of American families
into chaos if parents want to keep their
kids at home they should have the option
and they should be able to do that but
the vast majority of Americans don't
have the luxury to quit their jobs or
the skill and patience required to teach
their kids at home let alone multiple
children in different grades
now if already stressed-out parents and
isolated children are forced back into
this situation again the one they just
got out of from the spring expect a
difficult situation to get worse and
dramatically so Pelosi really cares
about the children then why hasn't she
spoken out about this and assuming Biden
even understands what's happening here
why isn't he pushing for safe safe and
sensible reopening zazz well
remember this is time for liberals to
press their advantage to experiment in
terms of how much they can push you how
much you will take how radically they
can change the old normal to prepare you
for their new normal so it's up to us to
conserve and preserve what we know works
students in class learning and growing
that's what works and that's the angle